uh before we get to the first headline
this is
uh I I think something I want to read to
you because it's very relevant to what
we just talked about you know I said
well
we know what allegedly some of these Top
surgery the double mastectomy victims
and that is by the way we should start
calling them as victims not patients so
we know what the victims say some of
them anyway three months after the fact
what do they say a couple years later
well uh billboard Chris on Twitter is an
activist that has been traveling around
the country to expose uh gender ideology
and doing fantastic work he posted a
couple things to Twitter yesterday
from the D trans Reddit forum
where you hear you hear the testimony of
of girls who have been through this
who have been subjected to this who have
been victimized by it
and their stories are just
words Escape you and to describe it I
mean to call it tragic is is to
understate the case
so let me read a couple of these two
um here's one this is someone who's 17.
here's what she says
I hate my voice every time I open my
effing mouth I sound like a freak I've
ruined my life with my stupid decisions
I made as a kid
the doctors Ruined My Life by allowing a
barely functioning mentally ill child
with severe OCD and then undiagnosed BPD
to go on hormones that would completely
change my body
I can manage to get the pitch of my
voice up relatively decently to the
point where it's always in the
androgynous or low female range on a
vocal pitch app
there's always something that seems off
it never sounds female always like a
very high pitched stereotypical gay male
voice or a male trying to force a female
voice and failing
I'm tempted to just stop talking
altogether in my worst moments all I
want to do is tear out my vocal cords
and be done with it
I've been on T for about two years as
testosterone although it was relatively
sporadic and it wasn't very consistent
with either the gel or the shots at all
I've only just managed to get off the
hormones now as the shots I was on were
very three were were every three months
thankfully not a lot else changed while
on testosterone no facial hair no facial
changes and I never went through with
any surgeries I'm still only 17. I've
tried watching YouTube videos like trans
voice lessons and absolutely nothing in
the in the videos makes any sense and I
don't find them helpful in the slightest
I'm legitimately suicidal because of the
decisions I made as a kid it's all my
fault
I don't know how like how long I can
keep doing this
well it's not her fault at all
of course this is what the kids are left
with they're left to feel like it is
their fault when it is entirely the
fault of the doctors and the parents who
allow this to happen entirely their
fault 100
and this by the way this is there's no
surgery here this is just quote just
from the testosterone
which we're assured is reversible it's
not irreversible
so this is what a child goes through
after changing
her voice
now what happens
when they go further than that
this is another one this is from another
user on the d-trans Reddit form
I'm a 17 year old girl with a flat chest
a deep voice a visible Adam's apple and
some facial hair there's no reason for
me to continue to live I destroyed my
life and I feel like all I have is
stupid for me to have all the hope I
have is stupid for me to have I don't
think any person will ever want to date
me before all this people were into me
but I destroyed that now no one is ever
going to like me there's nothing I can
really do without getting reminded of my
past and how much I miss it I feel
ashamed of what I did I'm scared that
people will never let me do decisions on
my own anymore
I was just a kid and I would have needed
someone to help me accept myself but my
therapist didn't question my transness
I can't stop thinking about the life I
could have had
I also think other people will now
believe that there's something better
than me
I love my mom she's an amazing mom she
stopped me the first time from
transitioning but the second time she
was also brainwashed and sadly thought
that when all these professionals say
it's the right thing to let your kid
transition then it must be the right
thing she thinks it's all her fault but
it isn't I want to kill myself but then
she'll feel even more miserable how can
I kill myself and let her know that I
want her to be happy I'm 17.
why do I have to think about ending my
life it's too much for me to handle
there's no joy in my life anymore
so this is a this child is 17 years old
and got the surgery there's another uh
post where she talks about she got the
surgery when she was 14.
so this is three years later and we
don't know exactly based on this when
the regrets started to set in but three
years later
so you follow up three years later still
childhood
and this is what you find
as I said words uh
cannot quite do justice
to the enormity of of the evil here the
the depths of the evil
the people who are pushing this and
promoting it are as I have said many
times and I and I believe with every
fiber of my being these are among the
worst human beings
the ones who are pushing and promoting
it and doing it
two kids
are among the worst human beings who
have ever lived on the planet
I mean they they belong in the same
category the Nazi comparisons and all
the rest of it are tired and overplayed
but but they belong right in that
category
in the category of the most monstrous
uh
demons to have ever walked the face of
the Earth
and there are a lot of other things that
we talk about
you know in our society a lot of other
issues we deal with other issues I talk
about all the time that we'll talk about
today on the show but
I can tell you right now and I'm not
going to be around to say I told you so
but uh
history books in the future
like this is the only thing they're
going to be worried about with our our
whole era of history in western
civilization will be defined by this
they will be writing books and history
books focused almost entirely on this
okay it's like when history books talk
about the 1860s uh in in the United
States it's there are other things that
happen besides the Civil War but the
Civil War is the only thing the history
books are concerned about in the 1860s
well when the when the history books
tell of the 2010s and the 2020s
this is what that chapter is going to be
about
and there are going to be debates raging
among historians for centuries to come
just trying to figure out how could this
have happened
they'll be baffled by like how could
this have happened how did how did
anyone allow it to happen
and I'm living through it I'm asking the
same question
and that'll do it for today
for this portion of the show anyway as
we move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]